Andrea starts off this hour in Alaska
hi Andrea how are you I'm a ceramic am
well how are you better than I deserve
what's up sort of a long story but when
I was 19 my father convinced me that's
the only way to keep our farm afloat was
to take out a $36,000 agriculture alone
in my name and it has been three years
and he has not made any payments and I'm
sort of at a loss for what to do now hmm
and so the loan that was taken out in
your name is it a lien on the farm
we put up collateral in the form of
livestock that we were going to purchase
what's the money and I think of sort of
equipment that we already owned okay and
what has happened to the livestock in
the equipment what has happened to the
livestock and the equipment as the bank
picked it up since you haven't paid a
payment three years no they haven't
taken any action against us
I was suggested I take I'll let the loan
go into deferment so they can take the
bits of collateral back but that would
break us whatever semblance of a family
relationship we have left okay I'm sorry
so you're you're 22 years old
yes sir okay and your dad asked you when
you were 18 to take out a loan and he's
not paid a single payment on it in three
years yes they've taken my tax returns
the last two years but that hasn't got
much of a dent in anything I know what
do you do for a living I'm an exception
do you live with them still thank you
and I got a school full time hmm okay
and do you pay your own bills I do and I
pay a portion of the rent yes for the
beef on the farm okay why don't we not
why are they not paid the payments that
they agreed to pay I'm trying to say I
tried confronting him about it and it
doesn't end well usually a fight
and then is things don't get phones I'm
so sorry
a horrible position for a 22 year old
young lady to be put in by her I
hesitate to use the word father what a
creep
so are you involved in your church in
your community I'm not I think you need
to seek some counsel from a family
counselor and maybe a pastor and get
some people in your in your corner
because truthfully what's happening to
you is called financial abuse your
parents are abusing you and they're
using their position and their emotional
stronghold over a young woman to take
advantage of you and really setting you
up for a problem that may take you a
decade to recover from financially and
so here's what's going to happen this is
not going to end well no matter what you
do you need to come to that conclusion
okay your dad is not a good guy he has
not done a good thing this is horrible
and it's not going to end well you
cannot make your father be okay can you
hear that loud and clear
yeah I'm sorry darling I'm sorry you're
facing this but you do not have the
power to make your dad be okay he was
not okay a long time before this
conversation came up and so what you've
got to do is just admit he's a mess he's
a hot mess and he's probably not gonna
be happy with anything that you do
because eventually they're going to
foreclose on and sue you a 22 year old
receptionist who's in school they're
going to sue you they're already taking
your tax return and eventually they're
going to sue you okay and they're going
to take the collateral because for some
reason bozo thinks he doesn't have to
pay payments I don't know why bozo
thinks this but he's crazier than a
being apparently
but I don't know who takes advantage of
their 22 year old kid anyway so I can't
grasp where this guy's coming from so
he's going to be upset he's going to be
mad and it's his fault can you hear that
yeah so you're gonna have to just decide
when that's going to be and you probably
need some good strong mentally healthy
people in your corner walking with you
to guide you and gently and kindly stand
up for yourself because you never have
you've been abused
you've been do you realize you've been
emotionally taken advantage of okay you
think that's the truth yes sir yeah does
it feel that way to you
yeah I mean you got crapped on didn't
you I mean really by your own dad I mean
he has not he's left his own kid
vulnerable
and so what if he were if he were to
grow suddenly manhood grow suddenly a
backbone he starts selling everything in
sight in order to keep his own child
from being harmed but this guy ain't
gonna do that is he probably he's not
he's not we know that by the fact that
you're in this situation to start with
and so you're going to have to start
taking some steps to protect Andrea who
is an abuse victim and you're gonna have
to decide what those steps are going to
be and none of those steps are going to
make him happy I'm so sorry you're going
through this hang on the line I'm gonna
have Kelly send you a book that I want
you to get a highlighter out and post-it
notes and I want you to memorize the
whole freaking book but certainly entire
paragraphs
it's called boundaries by dr. Henry
cloud because the you have had someone
walk over into your yard now they drove
a bulldozer over into your yard and did
doughnuts
okay they step all up into your stuff
here and it was your own hat which just
makes this heartbreaking but also very
very difficult emotionally to process
for anyone but certainly for 22 girl
living at home on the farm sorry kiddo
hold on Kelly I'll pick up there's no
magic answer to this except himself
everything and pay the bill and he's not
gonna do that he's gonna pick up we're
gonna send you a copy of that book open
phones at Triple Eight 8 to 5 5 2 to 5
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money let me go ahead and help
you because we have just finished some
identity theft or research and would you
believe that 14 percent of identity
theft is by someone you know and a
disturbing amount is by parents who take
out loans in their children's Social
Security numbers or maybe borrow money
on the farm and talk the 18 year-old
into it that's not identity theft but
it's so close that it really could be
put categorized in the same bucket of
slime scum that's what's in those
buckets your parents who take advantage
of your own kids
slime scum
[Music]